problem 10 John uses 2/3 of a cup of
oats per serving per serving to make
oatmeal how many cups of oats does he
need to make 6 to make 6 servings so use
this 2/3 per serving and he's going to
have 6 servings so it's going to be 6
times you know for every serving there's
2/3 there's going to be 6 times that so
it's going to be 2/3 per serving per
serving and we could even put units
there we could say you know / or you
know what / servings well that just
confuses it 2/3 per serving times 6
servings so that's just 6 times 2/3 and
that is equal to we could just if you
maybe it's easier to visualize in your
head is multiplying two fractions we can
write that as 2/3 times 6 over 1 and
that's equal to we could simplify it
ahead of time but or we could just write
that as 2 times 6 in the numerator which
is 12 and the denominators 3 times 1
which is 3 multiplying fractions are far
easier is far easier than adding or
subtracting because you literally the
new numerator of the or the numerator of
the product is just the product of the
numerators and then the B be the
denominator of the product is just the
product of the denominators 2 times 6 is
12 3 times 1 is 3 and 12 over 3 that's
the same thing as 12 divided by 3 and
that just equals that just equals 4
which is choice B right there another
way you could have done it is you could
have simplified it right here you could
divide the 6 and the 3 both by 3 so if
you had 2/3 times 6 over 1 you could
divide the 6 by 3 and the 3 by 3 so you
get 1 and then you just get 2 times
sorry
6 divided by 3 is 2 so you have 2 times
2 is equal to 4 over 1 times 1 and the
whole reason why you could do that is
you know this thing right here instead
of solving it up here I could have
rewritten it as 2 times 6 over over 3
times 1 and then you could simplify it
before getting to this stage where you
could just divide the 6 by the
three and you get a 1 and a 2 6 divided
by 3 is 2 and you get 4 I'm probably
beating a dead horse you know that but
just in case you need a little review
multiplying multiplying fractions you
just got it which expression represents
point whatever you know zero zero zero
zero zero zero seven in scientific
notation so the easy way to convert
scientific notation especially when you
have a number behind the decimal point
like this is you literally just count
the numbers behind the the digits behind
the decimal point and we have one two
three four five six seven numbers behind
the decimal point so our answer is going
to be seven this 7 right here 7 times 10
to the it's going to be a negative
exponent because we're going less than 1
we're going behind the decimal point
10 to the minus minus and I just cut it
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 10 to the minus 7 right
there and if you find this problem a
little bit daunting I have actually two
videos where I go into depth about
scientific notation so you might want to
watch those if you know just in case you
run into the opposite situation if you
had 7,000 and you want to write that in
scientific notation so in this case
we're going above well pause we're going
into the positive domain then you would
you instead of just counting when we had
a decimal like this you kind of the
actual digits you included the 7 right
that's where you got 10 to the minus 7
when you have something like this you
just count the zeros so 7,000 would be 7
times 10 to the 3rd if you want more of
the rationale of why that works I
definitely recommend that you watch the
two videos that I have on scientific
notation next problem the Venn diagram
below shows the number of girls on the
soccer and track team at a high school
so this is the soccer team this is the
track team and right here this is the
girls who are on
the soccer and the track team on both
the soccer and the track team how many
girls are on both the soccer and the
track team so I I kind of jumped the gun
they're telling us they're telling us
the answer right there there are six
girls this overlap region right if some
girl is let's say that some girl right
there she's in the soccer circle and
she's also in the track circle and this
number tells us that there's six of
these girls so there are six girls that
are on both the soccer and the track
teams